[Music]
hello and welcome to the DevOps best
practices in this video we are going to
talk about some of the industry best
practices which companies that are
trying to move to DevOps and people who
have moved to DevOps already try to
follow now this is not a complete list
and this is not an industry standard
list which will be followed by all since
devops is a field which is constantly
evolving so every company or every
organization have their own set of best
practices and they have a list of their
own which they try to adjust to their
rule but yes when we follow the
companies who are pioneers in this field
companies like Amazon Rackspace Netflix
companies like this what you will find
is there is a common pattern among all
these companies and there are a couple
of things which stand out apart from the
others and which will be or should be
followed by most of the companies and
the people who are trying to move to the
DevOps field or the DevOps framework or
methodologies now let's take a look at
them one by one and let's try to
unpacked what they really mean so the
most important thing which happens when
you are trying to move to DevOps is the
cultural change now no matter what kind
of tools you take what kind of
technologies you use it is the cultural
change which stands out let's say you
have the best tools available the best
technologies available at your disposal
you have taken a license for some of the
industry-leading tools for your company
unless the people who are going to use
those tools your developers your
operations folks your testers unless
they change their way of working the way
they think about software development
and software delivery you will not be
able to achieve DevOps to the fullest
extent that's what we mean by the
cultural change and not only you as a
developer not only you as the operations
professional has to adhere to these
changes but every single one in the
organization has to embrace this
cultural change now when we talk about
the cultural change one very important
aspect is to gain each other's trust
now let's say we hired a DevOps
consultant for our company or our
project and the person comes and tells
us that whatever we have been doing for
the past five years or ten years or
fifteen years is not the right way to do
this you have to change now that is not
something which will be welcomed by all
so how can an outsider come and tell us
what we are doing for past five years
ten years is wrong or it's not correct
so if you are the DevOps consultant or
you are the DevOps engineer you have to
tell your developers and you have to
tell your operations professionals that
they have to make changes to the way
they are working in order to get the
best of results in order to increase
their productivity then you need to tell
them in such a manner that you gain
their trust but how do you do that in
order to do that you first have to
target some of the things which can be
immediately done which can be
implemented immediately now that can be
anything you have to decide and think
about what that is now that can be a
very small deployment automation task it
can be a very basic provisioning
automation task or it may be some
automation of a unit test to make it
from manual to automated manual testing
so it can be anything that completely
depends on you and the project which you
are working on but the idea is to show
some results to the stakeholders that
way you gain their trust and they are
more receptive to your changes they are
more receptive to your suggestions which
you are going to make and that is how
you build the rapport that is how you
build the confidence within the team and
within the project there is something
very important to understand it's very
crucial that you build the trust and
that rapport with your stakeholders
without it you are not going to succeed
in your DevOps transformation now
connected to the second point which we
discussed the third point is also
equally important you have to involve
the stakeholders DevOps is called an IT
revolution it's changing the fundamental
way we have been delivering software for
the past 15 to 20 years or maybe more so
when we are talking of
this fundamental change we are talking
from top to bottom we are talking right
from the CEO level to the level of the
person who is an individual contributor
it can be a coder it can be an operation
sky or it can be a tester everyone has
to change their way of thinking everyone
has to adopt and be adapted this change
which is going all the way across the
organization you cannot have DevOps
properly implemented just with your
developers or just with your operations
guys or just with your testers or just
having a high-level meeting between
project managers and the customers you
have to include each and every one of
them and you have to involve all the
stakeholders in order to make a DevOps
transformation in your company project
or organization that is very very very
important at this time this is perhaps
one of the most important points to
remember which is a continuous learning
approach now when you start with your
DevOps journey it's like any other
journey you don't know the end result
and you don't know the outcome at times
you don't even know what is going to be
the next step so you make some changes
you learn new things and you build your
bridge along the way you try and
understand your peer group in most cases
you will find that in the DevOps journey
your customers are actually your peer
groups your colleagues you have
developers as your customers you have
your operations guys as your customers
you have your VMware admins your load
balancer guys your networking
professionals your storage
administrators these are the people who
you are trying to target they are the
end users for you and they in turn are
building things for the end users which
are the actual customers of your company
so it's very important to satisfy your
customers need and in this case your
customers are your colleagues you need
to understand them you should also be
ready to make changes if needed when you
are learning new things you might find
that what you thought was correct one
week ago or maybe one month ago is not
correct anymore that is not the right
way you should have done this so you
should be mature and accept the fact and
then make changes as soon as possible
this is something
very crucial and DevOps transformation
more importantly because DevOps is not
something which has been around for
years rather it's a new field every
single company is trying to move to
DevOps if you leave aside a couple of
the leaders once again like Amazon
Google Rackspace or Netflix who have
been the early adopters and who have
shown the benefits to the whole world
that yes DevOps is revolutionary and
increasing the productivity for the
customers and for the company in general
and you can deliver products quickly
with very minimal error if you follow
this approach apart from those handful
of companies the rest of the companies
or the rest of the organizations and
projects they are trying to move to
DevOps when you try to move to something
new you have to be ready to take failure
in stride you need to understand that
yes there might be things which might go
wrong the approach might be incorrect or
at times there might be a better
approach a better paradigm to be given
that is something very important to meet
at this time and that is where your
continuous learning approach comes into
the picture and yes when you talk about
continuous learning we are talking about
multiple failures since it's a new field
once again there is no set standard it
is not a field we already have a
standard set of rules where you do XYZ
things and not ABC things there is no
such list in DevOps at least as of now
so you need to be very open to the
failures and you should be absolutely
sure that there are going to be failures
along the way but don't think of that as
a negative thing rather take it as a
positive and then learn from your
mistakes next time you'll know what not
to do DevOps is a field where people are
trying to learn from each other I'm
learning from your mistakes you are
learning from my mistakes
the idea is to collectively not make the
same mistakes again and again that
should be the motto making a mistake
once is absolutely fine
twice absolutely fine but if you are
doing the same mistake again and again
without learning that's not a good thing
that's not good at all that means
something's fundamentally wrong which
has to be changed
when we talk about failure when you do
some kind of automation when you try to
achieve DevOps step by step then we talk
about targeting the low-hanging fruits
we are talking essentially about some
approach which might go right and some
which might go wrong so you have to take
into consideration that yes this is the
approach which I should follow this is
the step which I can replicate in other
projects and this is the step which I
should not be doing again in any other
project so collectively we all are
learning as IT professionals has DevOps
professionals we are all learning from
our mistakes now this is perhaps one of
the most important points which tells
you that you have to think backwards if
you have seen the Jeff Bezos statement
for the people who are not aware Jeff
Bezos is the CEO of the Amazon and he is
one of the pioneers he is one of the
visionary leaders today the whole world
is looking up to and he says we innovate
by starting with the customer and
working backwards
that becomes the touchstone how we
invent what he means is that he first
has the goal in front of him the goal is
to make the customers happy to make the
end-user happy and that he thinks
backwards how he can do that and then he
translates that into the daily steps or
daily tasks if we do the same thing we
can determine individual steps which we
do as a person as an individual as a
coder as an operational professional as
a tester so you have to always think
about your customers in other words
whatever you are doing on a day to day
basis you should be in a position to
relate your work to the end users think
about how the task which you are doing
today is going to be beneficial for the
customer tomorrow or the day after as a
DevOps professional our customers are
the end users who are our colleagues the
developers the testers and the likes
because they are the ones who are
targeting the end users so if you make
their life easier they will be able to
produce better results they will be more
productive for the company and in
general you are contributing your job or
your part to the company as a whole up
until this point we
been talking about the cultural aspects
and the behavioral aspects of DevOps
this point talks about the technological
aspect of DevOps when we say
technological we mean that obviously
DevOps culture is very important when we
talk about DevOps the cultural part or
the process integrity has a very crucial
role but everything will fall apart if
you don't have the right set of tools
and technologies to supplement what you
have decided to do as a DevOps
professional or as a project manager so
when we talk about selecting the tools
the most important part is to understand
what is right for you you should not be
in a mindset that you must be using the
industry standard tool think about what
is good for your company what is good
for your project what is good for others
might not be good for you so you need to
be careful you need to give it a proper
thought and even test multiple products
if necessary I will give one simple
example when we talk about configuration
management tools it's very difficult
choice between chef and puppet and some
other industry standard tools so how do
you choose one of them the typical way
people go about it is that they create a
two to three parallel environment they
set up the lab with some of the live
applications then they set up a parallel
lab and they maintain those applications
with the help of these tools for some
time probably one month two weeks one
quarter and then based on the feedback
and based on the experience of the staff
managing those applications they come to
a conclusion they say ok puppet is best
or chef is best for me or maybe ansible
is more appropriate for me and then they
decide on the tools and technologies one
more example can be let's say you have
been using teamcity for your CI purpose
for your continuous integration purpose
now just because Jenkins is more popular
than teamcity that does not mean you
should move to Jenkins rather you should
see your benefits teamcity
if it works for you and if you don't
have any reason to change if any other
tool does not create or does not give
you that additional value over your
existing situation then there is no
point in moving to a different tool
so any tool or any technology no matter
how popular it is might not suffice your
needs so be careful
similarly let's talk about cloud now
today everybody is trying to move
partially or fully from the on-premise
architecture to the cloud architecture
in cloud when we talk about cloud
implementation we have multiple options
we have an option of public cloud we
have an option of hybrid cloud and we
have an option of private cloud now
which cloud you move to or you want to
move to or how you decide is completely
based on the type of application your
requirement your security analysis and
what kind of user base you have all
these things play a major role which
tool is more popular or which cloud is
more popular does not make a difference
just because AWS is very popular does
not mean you should definitely move to
AWS if you move to AWS is it adding any
value to your existing project if yes
please go ahead and make sure to move to
it if not there's no reason you should
move to it you have multiple sets of
tools and DevOps and in general in the
software industry you have source code
management tools where you have multiple
options you have CI tools where you have
multiple options you have configuration
management tool which perhaps has the
most competition then you have
monitoring tools and log management
tools you always have multiple options
which tool you are using is very
important one important thing is to
understand how beneficial it is to your
project the second most important thing
to understand is how good they are at
integrating with each other I'm just
going to give you an arbitrary example
let's say you have chosen chef for your
configuration management needs and let's
say for a second that Amazon does not
have a great integration strategy even
though in reality it does but let's say
for the sake of example it does not then
it doesn't make sense for you to move to
Amazon as a cloud provider you need to
think of all that so these are just some
of the examples which we need to think
about by the way Amazon as I said I'm
telling you once again Amazon has a very
good integration points with
all of these tools and some of the tools
which you can see on the screen all of
these tools have really great ways of
integrating with each other once again
you need to have a proper plan and you
need to do testing you need to have a
lot of testing before you can move and
before you can decide on the actual
course that essentially completes the
best practices based on what we have
seen in observation and what we have
seen after checking various companies if
I could summarize all of this in one
slide it would be that the cultural
changes we talked about are most
important
over technology if your staff does not
have a mindset to change you cannot do
anything you cannot achieve full DevOps
or DevOps to a full extent unless the
people who are working on it are the
people who are responsible for the
change try to achieve some tasks
initially which will give you the
confidence and trust factor as a
customer for the DevOps people so it
works for everyone and yes all the
stakeholders as we discussed everyone is
involved in DevOps from top to bottom
you should be ready to learn new things
and you should be ready to unlearn all
of the things you have learned already
which don't fit with DevOps yes you
learn from your failures customer first
always as Jeff Bezos says one of the
visionary leaders of today's IT industry
and yes the tools and technology they
play very important roles in having a
proper DevOps transformation for your
company if you falter in any of these
steps you are bound to fail overall in
your DevOps transformation all of them
are equally important and all of them
have to be paid equal attention when you
are planning your strategy for the
DevOps transformation of your company or
your project so that's it for now I hope
you have found this video informative
and thank you for watching
hey what's become an expert in cloud
computing then subscribe to simpler
channel and click here to watch more
such videos turn it up and get certified
in cloud computing click here